so that leaves the other choice which is
Rex
okay so I have inconveniently use this
letter already so what letter would you
like me to choose being that I can
choose any letter I like they are they
don't why not okay
I mean it's not an angle but it's a
letter use a board I don't use that okay
so I'm gonna just call it up if theta is
relaxed which is X to the power of 1/2
what is DP Doron DX what a to read x1 on
to read X okay so far so good
what else am I going to need to do yeah
I have to change the boundaries gonna
have to work with what with all of these
guys here right so what will happen when
you think about this just pause for a
minute I'm actually going to do
something a little bit sneaky don't
write this down just yet if I think
about it as an indefinite integral this
would just be needed for me the reason
why I'm stopping this is because I know
the boundaries for me are gonna just
complicate things so if I think about it
as an indefinite integral and I work out
what the primitive is I can take
advantage out for the definite integral
okay so I'm going to temporarily forget
that it's a definite integral if I just
use this okay what's that going to turn
if I was I'm asking you this just this
with no boundaries
yes okay you've got all these pieces
yeah so what am I gonna do
okay so I'm gonna have to square
something because interestingly I would
usually say oh okay I'm gonna replace
that with a feel okay but in fact being
and I've just seen this I'm not gonna
replace that beat up I'm gonna replace
it with defeated on DX it's a much
better use of it right
I'm gonna do two things in one guy I'm
gonna change that route exits there it's
actually on the denominator and I'm
gonna change the variable addition cool
but that leaves this guy which is
unchanged right so what is X plus 1
yeah yeah to get to get and and X plus 1
out of this I have to square both sides
which will give me the square and then I
just have to add one do you see that so
if I'm now considering this watch what's
this all in one go let's put this in the
right spot so that lets put him over
there because I actually have a one on
relax in my integrand do you see that
what's going to happen this is 1 over 32
squared plus 1
there's the 1 over X plus 1 times I've
got one on root X in there so this is my
to defeat up on DX do you see that you
see what I've done
cancel cancel this is super easy right
there's that two out the front one on
you squared plus one
da da hey you came with that which is
just any of us isn't it okay so I'm
going to take that and now I'm going to
bring it over here okay just be careful
what are we gonna get what's gonna
happen
oh you did say we need um we need some
boundaries right you need some
boundaries we going to need to worry
about vanity this okay so yeah watch
right can you integrate this one ah
he's that he's a beautiful thing right
you usually would say oh I can't I
better change my boundaries because I'm
going to evaluate Thea boundaries not
expand Ares okay but he remember I said
to you Carnegie and I don't want to deal
with these limits and infinities and
zeros that could be so all I have to do
to avoid that problem is turn this back
into whatever the original boundaries
real where do you see that so now that
I'm going to put values into X I don't
have to worry about the feeder
boundaries I'm back in my original
language right is that okay so now that
I'm ready I have fully integrated these
things okay I can evaluate all these in
one hit okay having got that at Wesley
friend so I'm saying that bit so tell me
the first one I've got the limit as u
approaches zero of what to
to tan inverse of red X that's what I
said was going to be the premium
function right don't need to worry about
classics I'm bout to valuated it and you
add one plus I can't now I've got the
limit as u approaches infinity of this
other guy but it's the same it's the
same primitive function just different
boundaries yeah
how you doing so far do you see what
we've done so I've taken advantage of
this I know how to actually integrate
this thing once I do the appropriate
substitution I've done something a bit
unusual which is usually I changed all
my boundaries and variables and function
but he have come back to X so I don't
have to change my numbers okay let's
evaluate this thing what's this thing
going to be equal to or you do the upper
boundary first that's easy okay so
that's going to be to tan inverse of
root what one take away and then you get
a lower boundary but the lower boundary
in that limit so you just write down
there
okay now just pause for a second before
you write the rest of this have a look
I've deliberately tried to leave this on
the board here right even though the
integrand is not defined at the chosen
boundaries right the primitive is look
at this done as u approaches zero that's
completely well-defined what's it doing
what is telling this to me as you get
closer and closer to zero from both ends
it's getting to zero so I can deal with
that just fine
now I haven't left myself enough space
so I'm going to go on to the next line
but let's do this other boundary now
right again this part has an upper
boundary which has a limit in it so I'm
gonna go limit as u approaches infinity
this time on to us you see I had before
what happens on the end subtract okay
now this is really nice I don't even
know I mean you know what 10 m/s over 1
is the mass of one course is 4 but
doesn't add up
it goes away anyway yeah and so then
what I get is these two dies so you told
me that this one just two they attach to
0 yeah what happens this guy what's
happening is his his the tan inverse
what happens to tan inverse as u
approaches infinity
what's it getting to it's going
somewhere it's going to PI onto that's
what the equation of this passengers
right now it doesn't actually ever get
there but because I have a limit pair it
kind of does right so I say well this is
two times final two there's that two
came from there see that
so this in fact is just equal to PI and
now you can see what the reasons why
there are two big reasons why this is
such a famous result number one it's
it's like all kinds of unbounded it's
like it's unbounded that way the glass
Peter I'm bad at this rate goes to
infinity and what do you do with it
and this nice convenient result which
coincidentally this I believe also comes
out too or is it so you can see I can
take advantage of these these properties
here right if you can divide things up
they often become easier to do and if
your functions notify if your integrand
is not defined then see if you can
actually take the limits and you might
get something that is well defined at
the other end as I frequently do okay